Trabajo en la ciudad de Nueva York,
En una oficina donde se valora la creatividad
y ya estaba bastante establecido profesionalmente cuando todo comenzó.
Tal vez esto te pase a ti, o no.
Pero todo esto me ha enseñado mucho
acerca de la importancia de ser lo más auténtico posible en el trabajo.
Y ha desafiado mis propias percepciones erróneas
sobre lo que se necesita para tener éxito.
No hay una forma única de ser un líder.
Se trata de encontrar tus fortalezas y la manera de amplificarlas.
Antes, si una reunión era difícil, me ponía mi máscara de líder perfecta.
Ahora, puedo decir: "Dios mío, eso fue frustrante".
Podemos hablar de retos y luchas de manera abierta,
en lugar de que todos simulen que están bien hasta que es demasiado tarde.
Ocultar una identidad requiere trabajo.
Piensa en toda la energía desperdiciada fingiendo,
deseando ser alguien diferente.
Lo más interesante para mí, es que en este gran estudio sobre enmascaramiento,
el 93 % de los que dicen que lo hacen,
también creen que su organización valora la inclusión.
Así que, nuestros lugares de trabajo y todas nuestras voces internas extrañas
tienen un largo camino por recorrer hacia la aceptación.
Hay una gran diferencia entre adaptarse y disfrazarse.
Y creo que aprendí eso un poco tarde.
Personalmente, tomo todo esto como una llamada para ser el aliado,
como mi jefe lo hizo por mí,
para que la gente sepa que está bien abrirse.
Si eres gay o estás orgulloso de tu origen étnico
o tienes una discapacidad o eres profundamente religioso,
intenta ser tú mismo por completo en el trabajo.
Podrías quedar gratamente sorprendido.